monsieur chère amie génovéfains depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant nous sommes
collectivement confrontés à une crise
sanitaire sans précédent la semaine
dernière pour répondre à cette seconde
vague de propagation du virus le
président de la république a annoncé un
nouveau confinement
je sais combien ce confinement est une
épreuve pour nombre d'entre nous combien
cet isolement
combien le fait de devoir laisser son
activité professionnelle
combien le fait de devoir se couper de
celles et ceux que nous aimons est un
impact pour beaucoup d'entre nous mais
ce confinement
c'est sans doute la seule réponse
aujourd'hui pour limiter la propagation
du virus
c'est sans doute la seule réponse qui
nous permettent de vraiment faire en
sorte que notre système hospitalier ne
soit pas saturé vous avez sans doute
pris connaissance du nombre de cas de du
développement exponentiel de la maladie
aujourd'hui qui met vraiment notre
système hospitalier notre système de
santé en france à un niveau de
saturation extrêmement préoccupante
il est important que chacune et chacun
d'entre nous respecte ce confinement
limite ses déplacements limite les
connexions aussi
même au sein de la structure familiale
je sais combien c'est difficile moi même
comme nous tous je suis contraint
d'adapter les règles de vie c'est un
effort collectif
mais c'est par le strict respect de
celui ci que nous parviendrons vraiment
à limiter la propagation du virus
vous avez sans doute depuis l'annnonce
de ce confinement
le gouvernement a pris un décret qui
organise la reprise d'activité dans
certains secteurs
à la différence du premier confinement
vous le savez très certainement les
écoles les collèges les lycées
sont ouverts alors s'agissant des écoles
sur la ville ce sont 4000 100 élèves qui
sont scolarisés dans deux écoles
maternelles et élémentaires
nous pouvons compter sur la mobilisation
pleine et entière de nos équipes
enseignants de nos équipes de direction
mais également du personnel municipal
mobiliser pour faire respecter ce
protocole sanitaire nécessaires à la
réouverture des écoles
vous le savez sans doute le gouvernement
a rendu aussi obligatoire le port du
masque pour les élèves de plus de 6 ans
c'est la raison pour laquelle dès ce
week-end nous avons réceptionné des
masques en tissu et certains ont déjà
été livrés dans chacune des écoles
élémentaires de la ville dès ce matin
donc chaque élève génovéfains a reçu 2
masque en tissu dès ce matin dans les
prochains jours
deux autres masques suivront alors que
le gouvernement avait annoncé que ces
masques étaient à la charge des familles
nous avons souhaité avec la municipalité
apporter une aide particulière aux
familles génome fn en dotant chaque
élève de ses premiers masques sur la
mobilisation de la ville
je sais aussi combien ce nouveau
confinement est une épreuve extrêmement
importante pour nos professionnels nos
commerçants ils sont importants ils font
battre le coeur de la ville alors que
certains maires ont pris des arrêtés
municipaux autorisant l'ouverture des
commerces dits non essentiels je
voudrais à revenir sur ce point nombreux
sont ceux qui durant tout le week-end
m'ont alerté sur cette situation
je voudrais rappeler que un arrêté
municipal ne peut être pris en
contradiction soit à une loi soit un
décret ce n'est pas possible c'est la
raison pour laquelle les préfets ont
déféré au tribunal administratif nombre
de d'arrêtés municipaux que les maires
en question ont pris alors il ne
m'appartient pas de juger le fait ou pas
de prendre cette cet arrêté mais il
m'apparaît important que dans nos
responsabilités dans nos fonctions
respectives qui nous faille absolument
respecter le cadre légal
pour autant la situation de nos
commerces de centre-ville et je sais
combien nous y sommes collectivement
attaché nécessite des réponses fortes et
des adaptations du décret pour permettre
à nos commerçants de pouvoir continuer
leurs activités économiques je sais
aussi pour avoir échangé avec nombre de
commerçants combien ce nouveau
confinement sera une épreuve
juste pour la survie de leur activité je
sais aussi combien sont ceux qui
souhaitent pouvoir rouvrir leur commerce
ils y mettent toute leur énergie toute
leur vie face à une concurrence bien
souvent qu'ils jugent déloyale
je sais aussi notre attachement commun à
la survie de nos commerces de proximité
c'est la raison pour laquelle durant
tout le week-end avec l'association des
maires d'ile-de-france avec
l'association des maires de l'essonne
nous avons adressé des propositions
concrètes au premier ministre afin de
pouvoir dans le strict respect des
règles sanitaires avec cette forte
volonté aussi de ne pas laisser la
maladie se propage et en prenant en
compte les investissements déjà fait par
nos commerçants pouvoir ouvrir ses
commerces de centre-ville alors pour
l'heure la situation sanitaire ne permet
pas cette réouverture des commerces mais
nous
allons continuer la mobilisation de
façon à ce que d'ici quelques jours le
gouvernement puisse entendre raison mais
là encore je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est aussi collectivement que nous
permettrons à nos commerçants de pouvoir
rouvrir et je renvoie au strict respect
du confinement
enfin sur la mobilisation de la ville à
vos côtés durant sept durant cette
épreuve
sachez que comme nous avons pu le faire
durant le premier confinement nous
allons reprendre ses appels en direction
de nos seniors ils sont bien souvent
isolés chez eux ils sont plusieurs
milliers à sainte geneviève
lors du premier confinement nous avions
souhaité appeler chaque gène au fn et
chaque gène avait faim de plus de 64 ans
de façon à nous assurer que celles et
ceux qui sont parmi les personnes les
plus exposées les plus sensibles à la
copie de 19 puisse avoir une réponse un
soutien de la collectivité donc nous
allons reprendre ses appels pour nous
assurer que cet isolement de lait pèsent
pas trop pour s'assurer qu'il ne manque
de rien pour reprendre les portages de
repas à domicile pour aussi organiser la
solidarité pour aller faire les courses
quelquefois je sais là encore que nous
pourrons compter sur un grand nombre
d'entre vous dans cette nécessaire
solidarité
cette solidarité elle s'adressera aussi
en direction de nos populations les plus
fragiles les plus modestes
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
mettrons des budgets supplémentaires
puisque à cette crise sanitaire se joint
une crise économique et se joindre à une
crise sociale aussi qui touchera un
grand nombre de deux familles gêne au fn
alors avec nos partenaires nous serons
au rendez vous de cette solidarité
génome
fait par le maintien des aides
spécifiques par le développement des
aides spécifiques mais également par le
soutien à nos associations qui oeuvrent
pour la solidarité à l'échelle de la
commune et je pense notamment à notre
épicerie sociale la solidarité
et quand j'évoque la situation
associative
je voudrais avoir une pensée pour deux
groupes de secouristes qui sont présents
sur sur la ville je pense notamment aux
secouristes de l'ump s unités mobiles de
premier secours mais également des
secouristes de la croix blanche
ils sont en première ligne là encore
comme il l'avait été au printemps
dernier aux côtés du samu aux côtés des
unités de secours bas pour porter
assistance à nos populations fragilisées
nous serons à leurs côtés pour leur
permettre d'exercer leurs fonctions dont
les meilleures conditions possibles bien
évidemment cette période de confinement
nécessite que nous puissions vous
informer de la manière la plus rapide
possible alors au travers de nos réseaux
sociaux nous vous donnerons très
régulièrement des informations sur la
continuité des services publics puisque
à la différence du premier confinement
vous le savez sans doute les services
publics et notamment les services
publics municipaux seront ouverts et et
je vous un jeu vous informe d'ores et
déjà que nous avons souhaité vous
accueillir sur la base de rendez-vous
dans les services
administratifs municipaux c'est le moyen
que nous avons trouvée pour limiter la
propagation du virus pour limiter les
contacts aussi au sein des services
municipaux
bien évidemment comme il l'a été
demandée à l'ensemble de la population
française à l'ensemble des entreprises
françaises
nous avons développé le plus largement
possible télétravail au sein des
services municipaux
alors le télétravail quand cela est
possible bien évidemment puisqu'il
concerne les services techniques pour ce
qui concerne la propreté de la ville
pour ce qui concerne le nettoyage des
locaux notamment les locaux scolaires
des crèches vous doutez bien que le
télétravail n'est pas possible à ce
moment là mais pour ce qui concerne le
les services administratifs nous avons
largement favoriser le télétravail
néanmoins pour être à vos côtés durant
cette période toute particulière nous
avons souhaité maintenir d accueil pour
les génomes fn et les 9,1 qui ont besoin
de faire des démarches administratives
spécifiques et je le disais tout à
l'heure
donc il vous faudra à prendre rendez
vous pour pouvoir effectuer vos
démarches qu'il évoquait l'information
elle est nécessaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle donc les réseaux sociaux seront
largement sollicités durant cette
période c'est la raison pour laquelle le
site internet serein largement mobilisé
pendant la période
j'ai souhaité aussi comme nous allons
faire durant le premier confinement que
nous puissions pouvoir vous communiquez
directement par le biais de lettres
assez régulière dans vos boîtes aux
lettres puisque tout le monde ne suit
pas les actualités sur les réseaux
sociaux ou sur internet de façon à ce
que chacun puisse avoir les informations
qui concernent les services publics
municipaux et les règles qui régissent
le confinement je souhaite aussi que
nous puissions avoir ce type de vidéos
alors sans doute un peu plus courte
chaque semaine que celle ci mais il
apparaissait important de pouvoir
prendre un peu de temps sur cette
première vidéo de en ce premier lundi de
de confinement de pouvoir m'adresser à
vous de manière un peu longues et
précises
et puis comme je disais à l'instant nous
sommes sur ce premier lundi
en ce deuxième confinement et j'ai une
pensée toute particulière
en direction de l'ensemble des élèves
essonniens de leurs professeurs en ce
jour de rentrée avant les vacances de la
toussaint je sais combien l'émotion a
été grande
suite aux attentats qui a reconnu notre
pays et je sais que cette journée cette
première journée est l'occasion pour
l'ensemble des personnels de l'éducation
nationale d'avoir des échanges avec
leurs élèves
je veux leur dire notre entier soutien
dans cette période tout comme vous
pouvez vous toutes et tous compter sur
le soutien et la mobilisation de votre
équipe municipale de l'ensemble des
agents municipaux dans cette période
toute particulière que nous traversons
je suis certain que nous parviendrons
ensemble à limiter la propagation du
virus et à faire en sorte que nous
puissions dans les semaines et les mois
à venir retrouver une vie la plus
normale possible prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin de celles et ceux qui vous
entourent